fanny ferrée près par ses personnages
dans les moindres détails
des femmes des hommes des enfants des
sculptures en mouvement
je me mets à sa place et finalement
quand on marche on est toujours en
déséquilibre ce qu'on avance un pas
après l'autre
donc voilà je cherche toujours le moment
d écrire pour mettre le pas vers l'avant
c'est comme ça que je crée le mouvement
s'est toujours créer un léger
déséquilibre
voilà c'est ça qui est compliqué c'est
de gérer tout ça et la technique à la
fois de la sculpture et puis le côté
vivant quoi tout ça qu'il faut gérer à
la fois des fois ça tombe ça arrive
souvent
cette exposition à la collégiale
saint-andré en partenariat avec la
galerie capazza propose une soixantaine
d'oeuvres des terres cuites des bronzes
des tableaux de la vie quotidienne comme
ici les musiciens la photo de famille ou
encore la toilette
moi ce que je vois c'est que les gens
imaginent ce qu'ils veulent quoi ça soit
chacun leur histoire
l'enfance la famille la tribu sont
présentes partout
la commissaire de l'exposition a été
élevé en afrique
de nombreux personnages lui rappelle son
enfance quand on regarde le travail de
fanni je pense que l'enfant ça y est
toujours là les enfants qui dorment les
poupées le 2-2 contre n
les adultes sont très grands d'ailleurs
son plus grand en fait et est ce que
quelque part quand on est enfant soit
pas les adultes très grand et je pense
qu'il ya aussi cet aspect là plus d'une
dizaine de personnages sont réunis dans
ce tableau le passage ils sont sur un
chemin en mouvement avec leurs enfants
leurs animaux il renvoie aux grandes
questions de l'humanité
qui sommes-nous d'où venons nous où
allons nous si la plupart des sculptures
sont en mouvement d'autres sont posés
dans le jardin médiéval de la collégiale
comme cette femme avec son enfant sur le
dos ou cette femme aux oiseaux ils sont
là immobile
universel
[Musique]